a partir de este primero de enero la
estación ferroviaria de parís norte pasa
a ser un punto de entrada y salida de la
unión europea hacia el reino unido- o
desde ese territorio
una veintena de trenes unen a diario
londres y parís y transportan apenas una
fracción de esos 30 millones de personas
que cada año se desplazan en ambos
sentidos del canal de la mancha es por
eso que hasta aquí se han trasladado
cerca de 600 oficiales de inmigración y
aduanas para controlar no solamente la
importación y exportación de mercancías
sino también los pasaportes y es
precisamente ese uno de los cambios del
presi anteriormente se necesitaba
solamente una tarjeta de identidad para
viajar y ahora es necesario es
obligatorio tener un pasaporte a partir
de octubre de este año es una medida que
afecta no solamente a los viajeros sino
también a esos 300.000 franceses que se
establecieron de manera oficial en el
reino unido- establecieron su residencia
allí y cerca de 400.000 británicos que
viven también aquí en frase es otra de
las dinámicas del break city que afectan
a los ciudadanos de ambos países